cette norme nous allons écouter la voix
de la société maintenant c'est à dire le
réquisitoire de monsieur le procureur
général de la république des proches de
français
tout à l'heure il après votre défense 1
[Musique]
merci à ce matin outre aig est très
chouette
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les souris public chéri jean
cau et michel droit viennent dîner ce
soir peut tu pensé à prendre de bâtard
la série de votes alors si toi
non c'est une c'est une note de josiane
que je mélange est le bon pour que je ne
me retrouvais pas me non plus oui
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les jurés public lyrique
une fois de plus c'est un humoriste
subversif que nous allons guillotiné que
nous allons juger en toute impartialité
aujourd'hui certes il n'est pas le
premier pitre à comparaître devant c'est
parce que oui à propos de la note de
jeudi jan cools michel droit viennent
dîner ils viennent ensemble ça veut pas
dire qu'ils sont ensemble j'insiste là
dessus parce qu'il ya des gens
malfaisants qui hésite pas à coller
comme ça de nom ils disent pas les
souris dispose janko et michel droite
son ensemble et celle qu'ils n'osent pas
dire ça mais si nous tenait enfin ils
ont été trop peur du légitime procès en
diffamation que ces deux hommes au
talent ces deux hommes au talent
indiscutable ne manquerait pas de leur
intenter
[Applaudissements]
il n'est pas pas question de voir leur
intenter intenté comme une tente avec un
non et re on tente pour dormir dedans
oui avec dessous pas fan mais revenons
au petit larousse au grand robert aurès
sachant fort bien combien vous haïssez
les plaisanteries scabreuses et lesquels
sonades yves robert je me garderai bien
de risquer de vous déplaire plus encore
avec mes allusion parra pédérastique je
tiens en effet c'est une simple question
d'éthique professionnelle à ce que
jusqu'au dernier moment c'est-à-dire
jusqu'au vert de rome finale l'accusé se
disent ce procureur quand même qu est-ce
qu il est bien élevé bordel je remarque
crée donc yves robert ivre mort ivre
mort
robert que vous n'étiez pas le premier
comics professionnel à comparaître dans
notre sympathique tribunal d'exception
nous avons déjà jugé ici les pitres guy
bedos romain bouteille
rufus pierre rouanet pierre doris oui je
vous vois je me vois surpris monsieur le
juge je sais ce que vous pensez vous
vous dites pourquoi pierre doris
pourquoi le nom de pierre doris au
milieu de cette liste de clown
lamentable parce que c'est plus fort que
moi il me fait rire encore plus que
giscard
s'il n'y a pas de bâtard tac à prendre
deux bagues nord et l'autre ça ça m'a
pris une autre note ce temps perdu le
bourreau qui attendent la preuve de la
culpabilité vive robert étant ainsi
démontré de façon éclatante
il ne nous reste plus qu'à nous demander
de quoi tu es ce qu'on accuse ton comme
disait de quoi comme dit l'autre on vous
reproche de détourner les fonds publics
yves robert à cette grave accusation je
vous le demande
qu'avez vous à répondre rien bon vous
êtes témoin monsieur le juge vous êtes
juge seul témoin vous êtes il avoue tout
en bloc
vous êtes témoins à en croire le dossier
de l'instruction
vous semblez prisée au dessus tout la
vertu de tolérance yves robert vous
l'avez dit deux fois l'instruction
on ne peut pas vous en blâmer il est
vrai que si les hommes nous était plus
tolérant il pourrait enfin se mêler tous
ensemble dans dans un même élan d'amour
à mesdames et messieurs les jurés comme
l'humanité serait plus belle si tous les
hommes guidée par l'esprit de tolérance
mettait toutes leurs forces en commun
pour pour aider ministre les rues à
virer les arabes de france
donc vous êtes tolérant et moi aussi
mais la tolérance a ses limites
au delà de laquelle votre ticket n'est
plus valable voyez cet homme mesdames et
messieurs les jurés
c'est un homme à qui son pays confie
d'énormes subventions au nom du
ministère de la culture afin qu'ils
montrent qu'ils des spectacles et cet
argent il le dilapidons gaudriole futile
de style napoléon iii mesdames et
messieurs les jurés
savez vous seulement yves robert combien
de miséreux non ça on s'en fout combien
de missiles dans l'écrit savez vous
combien de combien de missiles
supplémentaires nous pourrions doter
notre armée avec le budget de la culture
que vous gaspillez deux noms
[Applaudissements]
au moins au moins ici et vous pu monter
des spectacles intelligent culturel ce
ne sont pas les idées qui manquent je
pense notamment à la chasse d'eau qui
est tiré d'un roman de nathalie sarraute
rabat le couvert je crois dont j'ai
parcouru les bonnes feuilles 6 me et se
verra si d'ailleurs j'en ai apporté une
ici nathalie sarraute c'est quand même
admis raf jolie horreur perplexité le
doute
vers quoi courir pensait jérôme laisser
mourir les dieux laisser cette femme
dans ce mirage laisser les lieux dans
l'état où je les trouvais en entrant
promise andry et j'ai d'autres exemples
monsieur robert pourquoi ne pas monter
une oeuvre aussi admirable que la ville
roland barthes par marguerite duras avec
paul préboist dans le rôle de roland
barthes ça vous aurez une de ces gueules
et pourquoi ne pas monter il est minuit
dr pinochet j'en ai parlé
personnellement aux professeurs lortat
jacob qui est un ami qui est président
de l'om ftc l'ordre des médecins qui
font de la télé pendant les heures de
consultation il a il a vigoureusement
applaudi avant de me faire une
intraveineuse dans la moquette
et plutôt janet come to me voilà enfin
l'attaqué personnelle contre
l'hameçonnage ne reviendrait pas sur
télémédecine de gauche
alors voilà deux grandes idées certes
ces pièces dont je viens de vous parler
sont très ennuyeuse mais en france
monsieur la culture c'est chiant sinon
c'est pas de la culture
[Applaudissements]
la culture chez nous monsieur zass
ingurgite les sourcils froncés et la
tête dans les mains et surtout ça rigole
pas ça rigole jamais alors votre
feedback merci bien
offenbach vous savez ce qu'il faisait
son père afin de battre il chantait dans
les synagogues
c'est un métier pour un français ça vous
me direz il était tellement est alors
allemand c'est un métier pour un juif
après la création de la belle hélène sur
le livret de meilhac et halévy le 17
décembre 1864 aux variétés théophile
gautier et théodore de banville
reproches et conjointement à offenbach
qui je cite de déverser sa haine
judaïque contre la grèce des temples de
marbre et des lauriers roses
or théophile gautier et théodore de
banville c'est pas des cons quand même
sinon il n'aurait pas écrit la mort du
loup ô combien de marins subversives il
est subversive votre feedback robert ce
n'est pas par hasard si on joue aussi
souvent la vie parisienne dans les
maisons de la culture gauchistes et des
cafés théâtres de la rive gauche
elle-même
vous êtes un mauvais français yves
robert qu'avez vous fait pour votre pays
rien en trente ans de carrière un seul
film de guerre mesdames et messieurs
la guerre des chaînes c'est quoi je n'ai
pas eu honte à vous mesdames et
messieurs les jurés je vous demanderais
d'être extrêmement sévère avec cet homme
il me semble raisonnable que nous lui
confions la tête
et croyez moi les bourreaux c'est pas
les carabiniers il pointe à l'heure
[Musique]
fait peu non non